so when we're talking about consecutive
we're talking about you know one right
after another
so and even numbers look something like
this
two four six eight
etc but say for example if the first
number let's just call it X we don't
know exactly what it is the next
consecutive even number is going to be
two greater than this one so that means
the next number is going to be X plus
two and the next number after that it's
going to be two greater so if we add
another two that's X plus four so we can
think of these as our three numbers but
now we're going to find the sum and we
know that the sum is 72 so sum just
means you don't add so we have X plus X
plus two plus X plus four equals 72 so
let's go ahead and combine like terms
here we have 3x plus six equals 72
subtract 6 from both sides and that
gives us
let's see 66 and then if we divide both
sides by 3 you can see that x equals 22
now we want to find the three numbers
okay that are consecutive that add to 72
X is 22 that's our first number the next
number is going to be 2 more so that's
going to be 24 and then the third number
is going to be 22 plus 4 which is 26 and
you can verify by adding those together
that you're getting a sum of 72 so if
you're enjoying my videos consider
subscribing to the channel my whole goal
for this channel is to make learning
math a lot less stressful so you can
raise your grade pass your class and go
on to pursue your dreams I look forward
to helping in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon